comedy because you think you're a
comedian
yeah it's normally I'm commedia but
right now I've turned it comedian okay
it's the end of this episode thanks for
joining us we're gonna come back next
week with when Mary goes back to the
mansion have a good week bye
so I tried to talk to Barry again and he
said he's keeping an eye on the
surrounding area just staring into space
she's not even doing anything he's the
worst
he's like you go back to that really
terrible mansion that I'm worried about
with all those zoms I'm gonna I'm gonna
keep an eye on this area that you just
solved am i done is that it because
there was all this stuff up here that
was in case you won't actually fight him
you can fight him can you shoot him to
death
let's go but let's reload the same and
try no time all right I guess I should
take those yes so putting your item box
at least
the helmet the arm helmet key is so much
more elaborate looking than any of the
other ones you can't can't speak to I
can't speak to good Resident Evil games
make me hungry
these Angry moths so actually I want to
go to the other typewriter I want to go
back through here
why because I already had a little save
there's like a save in there that I can
use on back to the to leave this house
there's also a typewriter toward the
front door that you're leaving through
right but I'm not gonna use it again
what like I'm not gonna come through
here again so why don't I just get that
little ink ribbon you got the ink
ribbons last episode there was too
wasn't there no it was just different
camera angle is the same one sitting
right here ah balls I'm so dumb I
thought it was here yeah yeah yeah I am
dumb yeah damn are you sure yep oh
that's a stupid what do you think the
guys name was that got stung by bees
Herman Melvin who is the guy from my
girl oh I have no idea
No Wesker Jill its kind of kind of a
classic joke what the [ __ ] was he
shooting at moths
I'll keep a close eye
maybe it's quite natural under these
circumstances it's not really our
standard operation
Jill our first priority is to get out of
here I agree there are still rooms in
that mansion we can't get into because
they're locked up I've been looking for
ways to okay if there's anything I'll go
back to the other mansion I'm counting
on you Wesker is so [ __ ] cool I used
to go into school there was one day I
went into school like with sunglasses
and I try to select my hair back yeah
it's dead spider era he was shooting at
the bees I was making a joke
I went into school when they try to slip
my hair back but I'd really like like
not flickable hair so try just a little
Wesker yeah it just stuck up and I want
I brought a walkie-talkie and then you
can walk over though oh right
it's a rite of passage you should go
back down and do it you have to do it
another plants dead yeah - like yeah
it's like pissing on its graves yeah you
don't control me anymore don't be so
[ __ ] funny if there's a different
plan under there not messing with you no
all right so I'm gonna do a few things I
just feel better healing so I think I'd
like to heal up before I save I just
would feel better this is all about how
you can worry about oh my god Ingram is
you have three four total one
so there's one there's two go I think
you go down I don't have as many as I
thought I did four five yep five total
four on me
I'm not gonna come back here am I is my
canteen full how do I know I think you
examine it I could be wrong or number
two yeah so it's full let's say I'll
fill that up too
good thinking but don't need to but
you're dumb the saves are I think the
most stressful part of this whole thing
like how do I know how many more times
I'm gonna need to save like I don't
it's all about I think it's less about
how much time you have left and how much
work you put in before the lab after the
last save all right so I've saved I have
aa [ __ ] so dumb
whatever whoa one what that's your
problem
go back go back to the iron box I'm just
I got to think through what you need cuz
you're not coming back here you're right
there there's more item boxes back at
the Mansi ohm yeah but I don't want to
have to go through another one I'd like
to just go right to the next this I'd
like to go to the next door you think
you're prepared right now for whatever
then go I mean I could take that shotgun
back
where's my shotgun why is this item box
so big all right I'll take this too I'm
good
do it up I don't wanna examine this I'm
so bad at this all right I'm ready dude
so I don't remember exactly which ones
used the helmet key so but first I just
gotta get back to that anylock door left
in the mansion is a helmet Keith or well
that's not true most of the doors all
right so I'm leaving cnl house I forget
where I am okay and then that's the
mansion up there I got really far away
that's like that storage shed yeah Oh
with the with the lady with the back
mm-hmm
oh is this the mansion with this way no
no no that's the cabin you're thinking
oh that's not what that's just like
y'all remember I have no idea I'm just
gonna go down this path
nothing bad what check out okay Joe I
hear you Brad over
bread bread
Jill - Brad can you hear me Brad Brad
[ __ ] it's broken
or he's on the wrong Channel he didn't
try that actually now if she heard him
really um so I need to give Brad a sign
maybe that I'm around mm-hmm should I
take these of mine we're gonna come back
here pull up your inventory yeah well I
I feel like I'm gonna say like a general
rule of thumb is to try to keep like two
slots open at least but once you know
the game better you know what to tell
you or nothing I forget oh I would just
dodge you've won shotgun shell or killer
I'm gonna give a [ __ ]
wait dodged one shotgun shell and I you
can you shot guns are ideal for the dogs
to the stopping power but you could try
killing with a handgun or just dodging
well I I can get rid of this if I do
that which is good right because we do
want to get rid of it but yeah you could
use it on something else running a dog
right right right
he's not coming after me well he will
when you get closer you can start
shooting now you have some serious shot
you you shot you shot you guys I don't
think he's dead oh wow I once hit
buttons BAM are you weren't yeah use
that I'm on caution oh right you're like
orange now you're fine don't use it
what's good you're good don't use it you
just said I got past yellow I know but
it's still costing you'll be fine
I'm gonna die if you hit buttons faster
next time you want I'll get his ribs all
right good
I just feel like I would combine though
it's just the safe space I just feel
like I should use it now cuz I'm on red
like if I get hit one more time am I
gonna die
no I mean depends on what hits you yeah
you could use you have to there you go
thank you
you don't have to do what I say I'm just
trying to lend guidance well I
appreciate your guidance alright
where the hell am I going don't want to
go right into this red door it's red
Drive I will there's no battery this
doesn't work
so this is later is my guess and then
there's this part up here Oh a blue
plant where'd she go it's true should I
be on there
alright why is it red if I can use it
it's what this windy dude doodle road oh
thanks gentle stop were they falling
from don't worry I'm poor you have blue
herbs in your item boxes where did they
fall from the trees I don't know
that's chit-chatting the tree I just
passed a blue thingy
yeah but going back there it also raised
the risk of getting poisoned
I am poison the risk is at poison
wait what I've been poisoned actually
wait go back
this is just gonna save time later go
back oh all right what am i doing I
guess I'm going through that arrow yeah
Oh blue I take it yeah should I combine
it with a green know they'll be wasting
the green here on your sewing green
health should I just eat the blue
sex you probably take agree with you as
well you sure actually now you'll be
back there here okay so going down all
these doors so nice listen such weight
and heft cause a lot of stuff here
helping you but there's so much [ __ ]
here should I take it take the stun
battery definitely you could take it all
if you want you have three spots and
your am I going to go to a save room so
you're almost back to the mansion so if
you need to ease or the safe rooms are
you're right near one okay that makes
sense
pick it up pick up all the stuff
pick it up [ __ ] girl maybe you should
move her closer to this gotta go mello
Yello rounds I have so much ammo and I'm
not using it
alright and then should I leave one in
there maybe read that was the sign the
wall says I'm from Wesker Barry
oh cool nice the door works he fixed
that piece of crap door they did dead
wait what
what's through that doubled those double
doors right there I don't remember
what's is it a crimson in the map where
am i there might be dogs in here go back
go back through those double doors I'm
blanking on what was through there this
one is here yeah those double doors down
under stairs
I didn't go in one of them did I really
great do you know I'm talking about here
to left yeah I didn't go in these you
just came through those oh go there's
these downstairs
yeah I'm trying out what's through here
check your map oh this is just to the
cabin that's right never mind you did I
did go through these ok those I forgot
it's been a while it hasn't been that
long
this place is a labyrinth what's this
again I already solved that I'm a genius
can you take that again though oh I can
take it
that seems misleading that you were
supposed to take it does the door get
shut off when you take it don't take it
yet do you know any in the door would
lock that's crazy it's a multi-use tool
all right I'm gonna collect my bearings
here I think there might be a crimson in
here I can't remember honestly I really
don't remember do that that's the
problem is like it's so easy to forget
and I don't know where I'm going I got
problems
I forget
that doors repaired now he just goes
straight to the safe room this door
right next to you is like the Spencer
family crest door whatever oh my god
what the [ __ ] was that oh my god is he
gonna follow me I don't know straight
into the right straight into the right
yeah get there is he in the safe room
nice pace yeah alright I need like some
heavy artillery maybe okay so once I use
this I'm gonna lose that shotgun no
you're gonna have the shotgun and she's
gonna have no ammo
taking up space you'd probably be better
off taking these solid shotgun and like
replacing it yeah I should just used it
I panicked
yeah you think it has good um I have
full health yeah I don't think you need
you don't need the first days Brenda
ready alright so I'll just shoot this
thing well you have six shotgun shells
here I think you also have a few more
like nine above above do I need all
these shells no I'm just saying no no do
you feel safe at 10 I feel like 10 is
enough to kill it yeah yeah do it up
like 10 should be enough well first just
so just so you don't lose the other six
at least combine the six with these nine
from the you have six more shotgun
shells down and low around the list I
just I want you to
oh yeah thirteen you have 19 others so
combine those 13 with the with a 9 No
there you go and but you also have like
take those now and then there's six more
down oh I just want them to get lost in
the shuffle you have a lot of shotgun
shells actually I there you go
I'm not saying bring them I'm just
saying just so you now they're all
together you don't lose them I mean ten
seems like a lot no you're fine yet I
would kind of think you used to save
right now you think he didn't kill me I
just thought you're saying this is a
good like checkpoint
I just saved I know but you made your
way out through the snakes and then I'm
gonna kill it easier than you thought
all they did hit you what are you are
you in yellow yeah the hunter will do a
lot of damage uh-huh I killed you the
[ __ ] was that oh my god giant like
battle toad
looks like he's pooping blood does well
when you exit your bowels when you yeah
and oft overlooked fact but I've been
next to many people who have died and
it's just have not it was part of the
part of the day job part of you feel
safer now part of life do you feel
somewhat safer no really
you feel safer if he was alive oh no I
just feel like there's more of them like
to me there's nothing about what just
happened that says now you're good
I'm against the Helmick you know so you
have you're making progress I wish it
was easier to do this but this I like
actually have to go through all this
do you like the like inventory minigame
in for how you have to rearrange your
inventory um inventory minute minigame
inventory management but it's kind of a
mini game of how you have to rotate and
move objects around no I I understand
what it is I just I don't think it's fun
to - Tetris things I don't that's what
gives me joy when I play video games so
should I save now because I've done so
well no I say you can hold off and well
you're back in the mansion now so it's
not like you can easily get to a save
room if you need to at any point in time
now that I've killed that thing yeah
what do you have in my inventory yeah
definitely have the helmet key got the
key I got a gun with some ammo I even
got a shotgun and I got some herbs just
in case I don't get hit
go to your safe box really quick I just
want to I was trying to think through
what are your next steps aside from
obviously losing the hell-like II I
don't even know because I wouldn't know
what's in there anyway
I got a square crank I haven't used that
in a while hot boss I got some that's it
that's all I got okay so unless I'm
gonna use that crank I don't need it
alright that thing better still be dead
oh my god why is he there well keep in
mind when crimson heads die and they're
not gonna reanimate they disappear as
well well I don't like it so where is
the first is it that room right there
the one on the right yeah like most
doors that are locked now we're gonna be
helmet alright so I'm gonna take a left
go through there okay
I swear I can't remember oh my god I
can't remember if there's crimson heads
I'm gonna take a right into this room
down the hall and it should just be
there such anxiety right now no you fine
Jesus the warm glowing room stop all
right should I take some of these I
guess I don't need them all right just
remember you got the second floor map up
here
yeah member for the worse
oh you're something sad jump-scare dude
that's such a sick rotating oh just the
noise it makes
yeah does sound nice John's on this game
so Titus oh all right so I'm gonna go
through here now mm-hmm sure did
you're making it worse for yourself by
like tensing up every time you go
through door why it's good to be on edge
because there's someone here okay oh
okay I can move that I will also observe
it
the left-hand side looks like someone's
face what do you mean the left-hand side
there that's like the only time okay
yeah it kinda looks like a skull I could
see it wait a child that's an old man
what are you talking about didn't they
say that this was a picture of a mother
and a child young adult that guy is a
[ __ ] old man looks like Andrew
Jackson they look like a married couple
that's not correct that's not right No
that tried to crush me
okay feel like I should have saved
that's a button is that it okay so I
feel like when I push that button it's
gonna go back it's not gonna kill me oh
my god I hate this
but when I walk through here wait why
did that happen
it's just automatically gonna close
nights a week the room would come back
but I can push that in there you're
right but it's too late now
it's easier if you leave the room come
back in as opposed to doing the switch I
see I understand you're saying I got Jim
it resets yeah gotcha
I think that those flames always sound
like a lurching corpse kind of thing it
was intentional I'm still not 100% sure
what to do though because even if I push
this in that room which is my current
plan so you know where I'm what I'm
thinking I can't get past it right
you'll see you'll figure it out
why don't want to get crushed you're
fine I'm it's it's gonna prevent you
from so it will prevent my crushing
promise Oh God
isn't that disconcerting itself it's so
upsetting
so I [ __ ] up no no you're good yeah why
can't I look at that painting I guess
this is not important I could move it to
the left or to the right can I pull this
stop [ __ ] sorry this is the all right
except I couldn't move
is that what I'm doing yeah I underst
gave you the middle finger I understand
them so now I'm just doing the same
thing yeah at the camera this is where
tank controls would be helpful like the
original controls the cameras switch the
area yeah cuz I yeah there we go
all right I got it [ __ ] sorry I will
say just keep pushing don't worry about
pushing it into the wall it'll happen
there you go there the first time I did
it I kept trying to push over and then
get it off in right oh my god that
painting is pretty dark get stabbed from
the back of him is that what's happening
I think so
stabbed through the back of the neck
into the throat maybe yeah and then
what's this one this one's a mystery put
this there that's very nice of them
Jamison Trevor it's a lot of defensive
items yeah I like them oh is that a pool
blood
a home I know I would if I saved I would
but I haven't saved who knows try go
down it's up to you I don't have
anywhere else to go
what's your inventory looking like
you've had you have numerous other doors
you can unlock you got shotgun shells
you've got mixed herbs I'd say you're in
good shape but if you don't feel all
right going somewhere unknown at this
point then by all means don't I'm just
afraid because I've actually covered a
lot of ground since I've last saved kind
of but it's been a really long time
remember the second my second I saved in
the other and I know but second time
through your knives timid you'd know it
to dodge the snakes come in and get
ready for the hunter it's really up to
you I'm not gonna tell you go down or
not but this is why this games good is
there so there's some [ __ ] down there I
got a lot of defensive items I say
you're in good shape for pretty much
anything I got a lot of defensive items
I got health and I don't think there's
gonna be a boss down there so I'm gonna
do it that's what I've decided I hope I
don't die oh my god I'm so mad
there's nothing down here you take the
last book exam it about any coffee
nothing exciting is happening in this
game right now I'm freaking out
we have a different Eagle of South wolf
of north
egle upon go to the page flip it to the
pages and then press a X oh that's
[ __ ] rude see I like that the page is
dog-eared there's three dots down there
you tell me nothing unusual I can't get
out I've tried every possible way to
escape but only to be faced with reality
that I am oh no Gio George Everest by
this point he's the architect to design
a mansion him and Spencer were the only
ones that know like their way around the
mansion right and Lissa is his daughter
that hulking hunchback thing now got it
the laboratory with the large glass
tubes filled with formaldehyde and those
dark wet and eerie caves first I don't
want to believe my eyes
but that familiar high-heeled shoe in
the corridor was my it was like reflex
Jessica don't want to believe they
shared the same fate as me I can't give
up hope I have to hope they're alive I
haven't had anything to eat or drink in
the past few days I feel like I'm going
Prez it what's happening to me why do I
have to die like this I was too obsessed
with designing this ghastly mashin
mansion I should have known better it
was a dark and damp underground tunnel
and another dead end but even in the
darkness something caught my eye
carefully the jolt I lit the last match
I had to see what it was a grave but
deeply engraved in the stone was my name
at that instant it all became clear to
me those bastards knew all from the
beginning that I died here and I fell
into their trap but it's too late now
I'm losing it everything is becoming so
far away Jessica Lisa forgive me because
of my ego I got both of you involved in
this whole damn conspiracy forgive me
that God justified my death in exchange
for your safety he did not know deal was
made
oh yeah I'm already down here so did he
not think to press a switch they're just
not seeing or little more events unfold
well George isn't here you gonna fight
it down like George isn't there ain't no
George so George must have gone in right
so George be down there mm-hmm I really
would like to save oh my god this sucks
aah you killed the other one pretty
easily with your handgun you can also
just dodge this one if you want I just
don't like to yeah you do have a lot of
handgun rounds and you're not gonna need
them
based on audio I think he's dead lovely
the one behind he's twitching I hate it
should I kill it how many are there I'm
not I like to imagine she just tried
putting her gun into the magazine what
the [ __ ] it's not working oh my god I
don't know where I'm going oh stop oh my
god alright I need to like understand my
process here there's so many corridors
and I don't understand where I am
alright so there's a door here there's a
thing on the wall back there - OH
there's stuff in there I should take
those I'm running out of slots oh I see
okay
so I've done pretty well I just need to
go through the store now no problem no
problem
I hear it
I hear it what is it my god I [ __ ]
hate this I hear you oh my god this is
actually hell I'm not walking forward I
have a defensive item okay I would move
from where he's on the ground I would
move actually they're gonna wake up and
I've already invested all these bullets
is he dead oh my god this sucks all
right that one's dead they're dead [ __ ]
that was alright so I don't have my god
I don't know if I can't light them you
don't need to come back down here also I
can't take any of those plants like I
could take one of them no don't you're
still even with defensive items great
net I'm sorry is that just a [ __ ] ton of
water I'm not going in there well it's a
video game so you probably have to oh my
god this area sucks
cumin oh I've been here
mm-hmm okay there was uh you're gonna
have to go into that water that you just
didn't like no trust me can I save I
want to say I don't like it I don't want
it to redo all this stuff I don't you'll
be fine
I went on that water really what if
those guys in a red and green herb
turning a crimson heads just don't go
near them wait
oh this isn't as deep as I thought it
was no misleading nope
where you going that's electrocution II
yeah
no yeah it's it's you're fine I'm in
water I know but it's like ground it's a
rubber handle look at it it's a valid
concern but we just literally had a
puzzle about being in water and
electricity you okay
you pushed an electric machine into the
water that you're standing in this one
was like a handle like it grounded him I
don't like II all right
so am I just leaving this [ __ ] them
yeah do you did you do you recognize
where you just were went through the
store the basement that kitchen I know
the kitchen yeah imagine if you could
cook a meal how far you have to walk
like around the hallways to get down to
kitchen George Trevor Jesus I really
want to burn that there just save room
not too far from where you right now if
you want to go up there
where is it up these stairs actually I
think you're gonna have to unload some I
yeah you're gonna found loads of items
all right well let's just go to a save
room then and save it's been a really
long time all right so where am I going
I'm going to the left and up those
stairs
yeah you'll be back in that original
hallway we saw the first time he ever
and he'll still be there no the first
one from that cuts me that you killed oh
right I killed that one was it nice cuz
isn't there an area with like two sons
and just two regulars arms in the
hallway to your right up here like where
I am no you'll be fine
oh my god I'm so turned around honestly
the dining rooms right near you right
now this was the last sword key door or
sorry so I want to go down this hall to
the door that used to be broken that's
now it's on the east side that's the
other typewriter door well there but so
I can't save now you can save but the
door you're talking about the oh the
door I see got it I got it
there's also a typewriter in here but
you saying I need to offload [ __ ] into
an item box yeah all right so we'll take
the door to the right and then the
second door on the left
I don't think there's also I want to get
rid of your key why there another one
maybe it's the same one no it's not
or maybe it is rumors abound about the
hunter oh my god I hate these things
alright here we go
get up get up get up starting to shoot
you
so I'm Trinity from the matrix what
she's telling herself to get up get my
god they're horrible looking he's super
dead no sorry I'm that like really
[ __ ] me up all right so I'm taking a
right on this hallway and then I left in
the second door yeah there used to be
two zombies in this always take kill
them
no they're just gone that doesn't make
sense they've been replaced by the
hunter did he eat them all right so
around the corner and then on the Left
Oh
this shadow scared me is there stuff up
there so the other Wow the only other
door on the first floor there at least
yeah that the helmet key is out in the
main hall
all right so I likey having my shotgun
like I want it you're saying I don't
need this right now
no no no you want the helmet key you
don't need the Eagle Crest oops I keep
putting things away do you think that's
about right I would
I don't okay I would reload your shotgun
I don't think you need extra shells
all right oh wait I'm such a dumb-dumb
I'm just gonna save remember you were
there
I would say you can go back and use that
elevator then do that and I'd be
actually good time down in the episode
okay hundred fifteen minutes yeah yeah
oh those things suck though frog men
frog men the Frog kid
you guys always sunny in philadelphia
not as much as you do no one does
when Danny do be I was talking about how
he got shanghaied up to the nitwit
school upstate and then did he live with
a frog kid named froggy
turns out just imagination but he knew a
girl the first kiss Frank ever had was a
girl with no lips and she wore a plastic
bag for the he'll make her she thought
she thought she was an astronaut kissing
the lipless I swear that's like a band
really uh it's a album name sounds super
unpleasant to say the least yeah well
alright so where are we going
should I go back to where that elevator
was yeah down to the basement to the
salah' that was stomp there was nothing
else in there that guy alive because if
he's alive I'm gonna be mad
what's up with that noise so I'm taking
her right yeah and then I'm going to the
left right
[ __ ] this noise that guy's gone great
didn't I kill him here so he's gone but
I killed him
okay make the noise
oh it's a door I also did not get the
noise at all yeah just try to avoid him
because I don't know if he's gonna wake
up he does look like a crimson head
right now so I'm just this way what and
you can wake them up I mean keep your
distance
can't hurt so I'm just going to that red
area mm-hmm
making progress yep that sounds nice
okay would you hate it if zombies
flooded the elevator yeah me too that's
not God where am i all right wait hold
on a second do you hear that noise right
now no not now but like it's the
footsteps
just sounds like a regular zombie right
I just wouldn't my point being don't
wait shotgun shells on him
but I should kill him if you want to you
probably dodged nice wait where did that
one come from I'm so confused
I need you to go through that door
didn't I go through it
I can't see don't let him grab you from
behind and you're not gonna use it
defensively that sucks
thanks I got crimson head at least I
would get more distance from that dude
to shoot him he's dead the first day oh
yeah you're right cool alright so wait
else was there to do in here oh there's
the door over on the other side yeah
just random naked girl like so
of a naked lady a gotta wait there's
more up there I think sixth on gun why
are you so jealous of my stun gun round
wait don't go up here there's nowhere
else to go
to toys you go through there's the
double doors I know I'm just and that
has no knob and then there's this right
well you're gonna have to go through
both the doors eventually just I'm just
telling you can unlock this one it's a
shortcut the gray one or the red one the
red you want me to do the red first yeah
okay it's hard to explain where that is
but you'll get if you go through there
so I want to go down no you know I get
what you came down here for which is in
here feel like you're like trying to
tell me secrets wait I feel like I want
that hey I think I know where that goes
all right all right
I am the battery Queen Oh a second yeah
you do pretty nice to have mm-hmm
so are the magnum rounds magnum rounds
are very very good I take those too wait
you'll see when you realize what kind of
shortcut that opened up you'll be fine
so yeah take those two oh I see imma be
honest with you I didn't see those no uh
yeah so you're good in here for now you
got the battery you know what to do with
it but you don't need to use it yet like
it's probably a good place to end the
episode actually went into a safe room
you know to save it we could just come
playing but at least and the episode so
yeah
you'll recognize where you are once you
come through here
because I just saved yeah we don't have
to say but probably just get to a safe
room so some items kind of recognize
this dining room through that door yes
that's always been locked since like
beginning a game not anymore
correct
yeah quickest a room would be down the
hallway but should I save again no no
just get to the item box in the same
room though got it so I'm going down the
long hallway upstairs Downstairs no it's
just through the door you'll see I don't
see anything
just go I'll see you back here now yes I
remember there's a hunter down the
hallway thank you I'm joking
music
that's the shortcut to your left to the
saver hallway remember this area now yes
but it's still pretty confusing to be
honest video like so that is a helmet
key Daugherty left but you don't have
room in inventory so I don't think it's
worth opening it well I could open it
it's not gonna get you any close to
discarding it though like I'd say it
next episode after the save room come
back up here use it it just helps to
keep that locker now so you could see on
your map where you need to go right I
understand okay I got you
so stairs yeah safe rooms right the
bottom stairs for the serum room so you
have the battery for the elevator
outside you have the helmet key know
what two or three more how Mikey doors I
think now I should probably take
something to like protect myself with
like what we mean well do I have enough
to like save myself because I'm going to
all these new areas that are pretty
scary get more than that though actually
oh you think I'm doing now you have your
six in your gun eighteen is really good
actually
okay
should I take my lighter in my foot put
the battery away for now but I'm no I
would say you'd do all the Helmke doors
before you go back outside all right so
I'm good yeah that's good you take a
bottle sure fill it with a serum all
right cool sweet it's good episode
you got more done than it might have
felt like I think there's just no
climactic but you saw the hunter hunters
yeah I hate them I hate them so much
alright well that sounds good and we'll
we'll pick this back up right here on
the next episode of resident evil thank
you guys for joining us
don't forget to Like and subscribe thank
you guys for hanging out with us was
that sound of one hand clapping I'm not
applauding you